demo yourself whatever product or
service you're trying to sell if you
want people to believe in what you're
doing a great way to show them is
through a demo as an entrepreneur you
should be doing something different you
should if you're doing the same thing as
everybody else you're not going to have
outstanding success you're going to fail
like most entrepreneurs eighty percent
of companies fail that's going to be you
if you do what everybody else does so
you have to do something different the
challenge with different things is it's
harder for people to understand and a
great way to reduce that fear is to demo
show them the results show them the
benefits of working with your company
because you could have the greatest
vision the greatest mission the greatest
intentions and purpose in the world but
if people don't buy from you if they're
not spending money with you you're not
going to be able to build a successful
company and you're going to see other
people with inferior ideas make huge
dollars because they did a better job of
explaining and demoing and showing
people what they're all about so while
it may make sense to you that this is a
great idea you have to quickly
articulate it and ideally demo it to
your target customer so they can
understand it buy it tell their friends
and spread the word for you one of my
favorite examples of the demo is a guy
named Richard Davis who started he had
the first all Kevlar bulletproof vest so
he created this all Kevlar bulletproof
vest and he wanted people to to buy it
and you want the police stations and
anybody who needed bulletproof vest and
at first he didn't have success saying
hey had this bulletproof vests you guys
should buy it because it was new in the
industry and people didn't believe that
it worked and nobody wanted to test it
on themselves like who would want to be
shot as a demo so what he did and it's
crazy but it showed how well how well
his product work he went to police
stations strapped on the vest took a gun
pointed it towards himself and shot
himself and you wash it and and you're
worried for him and
you think okay I hope this thing works
but this guy is standing behind his
product and it did work and that's how
people bought it you go to police
station you do this demo you shoot
yourself you see that this bullet did
not go through and it's a convincing
demo and people will want to buy it so
you need to find a way to show the
results of your product or service the
better you can demo it the easier it's
going to be for somebody to understand
so it's not just words you're saying but
they get the feeling and they get the
results it's easy for them to say yes
it's easier for them to buy more and
more from you it's easy for them to
spread the word and tell their friends
and it becomes easier for you to build a
successful company and get the results
you're looking for so search deep and
find the best way to be able to demo
your product to your prospects believe
for those are you watching you like the
video please give it a thumbs up below
and I want to hear from you please leave
a comment let me know what you think let
me know if you liked it or not the
comments always make my morning every
day when I mean you my my lentils for
breakfast so thank you and if you have a
question leave it in the comment section
below and I'll do a video response thank
you guys I'll see you soon